uh breaking news just reaching us here
at sky center have a look at these
amazing pictures climate activists uh
disrupting petrol supplies by holding
protests at oil refineries they are
literally gluing themselves to the road
as we speak um hannah thomas peter has
more for us um hannah what can you tell
us
hi good morning i'm sorry very dynamic
situation here so you'll have to be
there with us we'll be moving around by
the police but earlier this morning a
number of just all activists blocked
we'll show you the shot now paul if we
if we can lock this road in perfect near
a big
garage and um
across the road a number of arrests now
from
one hand
harder of course to unglue
those people who submitted themselves to
the road that requires a special
solution
but an uh
a big traffic problem of course of
course which is the point and a number
of uh protesters who find it on top of
tankers i'll see if i can have a quick
chat now with one of these activists
good morning madam you're live on sky
news just describe what's happening to
you to your hand there and then we can
talk about why you're here
they're just putting solution on my hand
to take to take the glue off and why are
you here today please
um i'm here today uh to
[Music]
send a clear message to the government
that they must stop funding new oil and
gas projects
we have eight years of oil in this
country we don't need any more
we have three to four years
to do something about our emissions to
do something drastic
before it's too late
we know that the british public cares a
lot about climate change but a lot of
them really disagree with these methods
it causes huge disruption and real
economic pain for those people who can't
get to work we've heard people swearing
at you and beeping at you people driving
tankers who now can't move goods and
services around the country what do you
say to them we're really sorry that
they're caught up in this we don't want
to be here and we're really very sorry
that it's affecting them however we are
in a climate emergency and we have to
act we have to start
moving away from oil
moving to green energy
reducing our emissions drastically or
they won't have a future to work in
thank you so much for talking to sky
news
so this activism ongoing today part of a
planned month of activism around the
country targeting specifically
the movement of oil and the extraction
of fossil fuels from the uk's north sea
okay thank you